la gonorrea es un tipo de enfermedad o
infección de transmisión sexual
frecuente a veces se la conoce con el
término del argot purgación
los gérmenes que causan la infección son
bacterias diminutas llamadas neiseria
gonorreae la gonorrea se puede contraer
de una persona infectada durante el sexo
vaginal anal u oral y si una mujer
embarazada tiene gonorrea puede
transmitírsela a su bebé Cuando esté
atraviesa el canal de parto durante el
parto
en el organismo la infección comienza
cuando las bacterias se adhieren a las
células del tejido que recubre muchas de
las cavidades corporales denominado
epitelio mucoso una vez adheridas las
bacterias comienzan a invadir este
tejido
con el tiempo a medida que las bacterias
se multiplican y dañan las células
provocan la entrada de células
inmunitarias en el tejido esto inflama y
daña el tejido mientras las células
inmunitarias intentan eliminar la
infección
desafortunadamente las bacterias tienen
maneras de evitar que las células
inmunitarias las eliminen esto les
permite crecer y propagarse por el
organismo
el principal factor de riesgo de
contraer la gonorrea es tener sexo oral
anal o vaginal con una persona infectada
tienen un riesgo mayor las personas
sexualmente activas que tienen más de
una pareja sexual son adolescentes o
adultos jóvenes o son hombres que tienen
sexo con hombres muchas personas no
presentan síntomas pero si una mujer
presenta síntomas estos pueden incluir
secreción anormal de la vagina sangrado
vaginal entre ciclos menstruales
sensación de ardor al orinar
un hombre puede presentar síntomas
similares como secreción anormal del
pene
sensación de ardor en la punta del pene
o al orinar dolor en uno o ambos
testículos
tanto en hombres como en mujeres la
gonorrea también puede infectar el recto
que es la última parte del intestino
grueso los síntomas de infección en el
recto pueden incluir picazón o secreción
anormal del ano dolor durante la
defecación
Si no se la trata la infección puede
causar enfermedad inflamatoria pélvica
en las mujeres esto significa que la
infección se ha propagado por los
órganos reproductivos en los hombres
puede provocar epididimitis la
epididimitis es la inflamación e
hinchazón del tubo en espiral conectado
a los testículos llamado epidídimo lo
positivo Es que la gonorrea puede
tratarse con éxito Con antibióticos como
la ceftriaxona también es posible que le
receten un segundo antibiótico como la
doxiciclina para tratar una posible
infección por otra enfermedad de
transmisión sexual llamada clamidia las
personas que contraen gonorrea suelen
infectarse al mismo tiempo con clamidia
Es importante saber que el tratamiento
quizás no repare ningún daño que la
enfermedad ya haya causado en el
organismo después del tratamiento es
esencial hacer un seguimiento con el
médico para confirmar que la infección
haya desaparecido ya que algunas
bacterias se han vuelto resistentes a
los antibióticos puede reducir el el
riesgo de contraer gonorrea si solo
mantienes relaciones sexuales con una
pareja estable que no tenga relaciones
sexuales con otras personas y que haya
obtenido un resultado negativo en la
prueba de detección de gonorrea además
puede practicar sexo seguro lo que
significa tomar medidas antes y durante
las relaciones sexuales para evitar
contraer o propagar la gonorrea por
ejemplo utilizar preservativos de forma
correcta cada vez que tienes relaciones
sexuales puede reducir el riesgo la
forma más fiable de evitar contraer
gonorrea es practicar la abstinencia lo
que significa no practicar sexo vaginal
anal oral
para saber más sobre la gonorrea
consulte a su médico